um listen what do we got do we got some
feels no facts no no no no we got
Francis Inu and Tyson Fury yeah yeah
yeah unbelievable amazing fight amazing
fight high level boxing shout out to
Francis unbelievable I mean what this
guy did is say again okay so let's go
honest assessment of the scoring what
did you think it was if if just honest
assessment yeah I said in the group chat
I thought it was 55 and then with the
knockdown with the knockdown I give I
had it 64 tyon and then with the
knockdown I had him winning by one point
okay uh sorry who winning by one point
Tyson winning by point he won 6'4 and
then he's a 108 because of the knockdown
so I had him winning by one point but I
wouldn't have been mad at it the other
way I think that's kind of how I had it
okay so it's like I think I had Tyson
winning but because Francis was coming
you know from such a deficit the fact
that he closed that Gap is the victory
yeah like I I don't know if the decision
is awful when you really think about it
because people were a little bit uh you
know there wasn't unanimous support for
one decision there are people that
thought Tyson won narrowly and there are
people that thought Francis won narrowly
and that's exactly what the scorecard
show right but um the judge who had it
like that was kind of crazy there was
one that had it far right for Tyson
right what the [__] 9693 or something
like7 93 something crazy like how's that
even possible with a 10 I don't even
know but Francis I think the most
impressive thing with Francis was the IQ
like his boxing IQ was insane yeah like
he knew what Tyson was doing and he was
he had a plan of attack to mitigate it
and then after he did it he was
countering it so that knockdown that he
got Tyson throws Tyson has his great
foot movement great head movement strong
jab but his main attack is a one-w and
he he does a lot of pump fakes to get
you off your Rhythm and then he sets you
up and then onew sometimes they'll come
in with the hook Francis was waiting for
the onew and then trying to counter with
that big hook landed it dropped him and
an interesting thing happened Francis
realized that Tyson couldn't hurt him he
could walk through anything Tyson could
throw yeah keep in mind this is who I
think is the greatest heavyweight of all
time I've said on this podcast Tyson
Fury is the greatest heavyweight of all
time so Francis went up against the
greatest heavyweight of all time M and
almost beat him and if there's a
rematch if Francis knows he can't get
hurt he was walking through punches
walking through elbows yep yeah the
elbow is crazy go like this go like this
you got little damn I tried to tell for
the break can you just look in your
phone oh gosh you got it done so it's
like he's throwing serious [__] and
Francis is walking through it and then
Tyson knows he cannot walk through
francis's [__] yeah yeah he got gotam
and once that Dynamic happens in a fight
now it's up to Tyson to really outbox
him you got to move back you got to
stick that jab and you got to score
points you know you can't knock him down
that's what I thought he did he just
scored points exact cuz but think about
that he's going in there going I'm going
to teach this guy a lesson I'm going to
spark him he literally says when he
starts the first round he goes welcome
to class and then when Francis knocks
him down he goes what happened
Professor I mean amazing and there was a
moment I think where Francis started to
realize oh [__] this isn't as hard as I
thought it was going to be I'm gonna be
all right now to be fair Tyson came in
sloppy it looks like he barely even had
a camp he had no strategy whatsoever I
don't even think he took the thing
seriously um no no it's not worth making
the the what's it called creating the
caveat for him of course and also like
you're getting paid so much money from
Saudi Arabia like they're probably
overpaying so much to hold the fight
there you show up in shape yeah you show
up ready and you put on a [__] show
like it's if I'm Saudi Arabia I mean you
had this amazing fight but I'm also like
hey dude yeah I I don't care if you
don't respect your opponent I'm paying
you crazy I'm pay you respect the pay
I'm giving you exactly respect the
payday because you're not just doing a
pay-per-view they're overpaying so the
fight is there yeah so it's like so the
amount of money they must have paid like
you know they flew all those celebrities
out there I don't think a single
celebrity all these Champions waiting in
the hallway just to give a Dap to Tyson
on his way to the ring did you see that
the amount of people that the amount of
people was insane it was like
vanderfield can't afford his own ticket
out
of but like Tyson McGregor Cristiano
Ronaldo crazy everybody those three
Oscar De La Hoya Larry Holmes I mean I
don't think we've seen that since Mike
Tyson like where every fighter came out
Marco Antonio they had every champion in
the last like 40 years there from all
these different weight divisions it was
unbelievable and um I mean they must
have lost in Crazy money doing it right
but imagine but what what did they
really win yeah like now we're looking
at this as a destination even the show
that they put on like I don't give a
[__] for music before sporting events
but I'm looking I'm like this is a hell
of a [__] show like these people are
out here I think the perception of Saudi
Arabia from the West is uh sand oil yeah
Black Cube mhm that's it now I think
through the whatever Sports washing or
and these other things they're doing I
think and they're building these nice
hotels and stuff I think we're starting
to go oh is this another version of
Dubai yeah is this another version of
the Emirates oh wow and they got enough
money to fly every single person out
there oh they got some Bouie [__] going
on here and entertainment that I'd be
into sportswashing Works
yo nobody's giving them credit for a
brilliant idea really great marke they
at every state in America want a sports
team that's true they're trying to wash
their state I you I always thought
Kansas City was just like booming
Metroplex cuz I grew up watching
football then I go there I'm like it's a
country ass town but the football team
they Sports watched it into me thinking
that's what North Korea needs bro they
need Chernobyl Chernobyl needs a
football team
Isotopes bro imagine dude it's awesome
so yeah so it was just a I mean the
winner in this fight is like I think
they need to fight again and Tyson needs
to prove that he wasn't prepared for it
and he needs to dominate him because
it's a little bit of a knock on his
legacy again I was going to ask you do
you still think he's the greatest heav I
think he's the greatest of all time but
it is a knock on his legacy and what I
would rather do is give Francis Credit
for his greatness than take away Tyson's
cuz if I go he was that good that's an
insult to Francis I'd rather go this is
the greatest guy and it just so happens
this Francis enanu guy that absolutely
dominated the UFC is so [__] talented
that he could dominate in boxing too you
know what I mean like if we cut the
impressive y your first
boxing your first boxing match is
against the greatest boxer in history
and you potentially outbox him yeah you
knock him down once but it's not like
he's just going and throwing Haymakers
he made Tyson afraid to throw yeah yeah
Tyson's the greatest boxer of all time
he's not just a guy like Deontay Wilder
who's got the nuclear [__] punch he
sits you down it's over he will outbox
anybody and you were right in front of
him and he was afraid to throw mhm now
in fair to Francis wasn't he a boxer
before UFC I mean like in the in the way
that you learn boxing as one of the
disciplines before you get into MMA he
had a little background in it he has the
background that I have it's like LeBron
played
football in high school yeah and then
you just go become a basketball player
and to that end I don't know how you can
and I I love both of them but I don't
know how you can not take some credit
away from Tyson because if Tom Brady the
greatest football player of all time
played LeBron one-on-one and lost 119
I'd be like yo I I'm judging LeBron a
little bit like that shouldn't happen I
don't care how good good Tom Brady is at
basketball I'm judging you 100% 100% And
I think that we try to justify it by
going oh Tom wasn't taking it that
seriously LeBron sorry sorry LeBron
wasn't taking it that seriously where in
this
circumstance I'm like this Ain this
boxing it ain't basketball like you got
to take this [__] Ser you get knocked
the [__] out so it's like I know you
were taking it seriously because you got
dropped yeah yeah I guess in my brain
the prep you didn't take seriously oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's where you
come in slopp sure but at the same time
it's like you've been preparing since
you were 5 years old like Tyson doing 12
rounds he can do with no training camp
he's been boxing so long you definitely
give credit to Francis for sure I just
think you also have to to me it's like I
can't not look at I can't look at Tyson
as the greatest right now if they run
him back and then he it'ss no problem
and it's like all right fine this is all
forgotten but right now I'm looking at
Francis super impressed but I am also
looking at Tyson
like really greatest heavyweight of all
time that's what my friend who knows
boxing always says but I'm looking at it
as a guy donees watch a ton being like I
don't know man that seems crazy I mean
there's only one person that I think
could potentially beat him that has a
chance and it's Lennox Lewis because you
need some with the size I mean Tyson's
5'9 Mike Tyson at 510 sorry Tyson is 69
oh yeah Mike Tyson at 510 it can't yeah
the arms won't even re it's it just
can't it's too much F 69 can move jab
throw punches balance
amazing what do you think of Francis
doing other boxing matches I mean go for
the money what I want is the UFC to
resign him and then give him the B kind
of and then just be like and I want him
no no and give him the bag give him the
the problem is they're not going to give
him the bag and the freedom because then
they'll have to do that with all the
other Fighters but I want him to go back
and get the bag and because then the UFC
has the baddest man on the planet the
baddest man on the planet we know right
now yeah is named FR Francis in and
that's no knock on Jon Jones but Jon
Jones just tore his Peck he's out of the
fight um I'm also looking at this like
if I'm Jon Jones I don't want to fight
Stipe if I want to go down as the
baddest man ever which that's what
everybody thought Jon Jones was before
this fight I got to fight that Francis
andano dude and let me tell you
something if Francis nanu can maintain
distance between 69 Tyson Fury and
himself I don't care
who anybody else is you are not taking
it lightly coming in for a shot on
Francis well Jon Jones out wrestl him
sure is is better but did you see the
way that Francis was throwing Tyson Fury
around the ring in the clench Tyson
never felt that in his life every boxing
match Tyson he looked a little surprised
like what the [__] anytime they clinch
up usually what Tyson can do to clinch
he's so big and so strong he can just be
imposing and lay on the guy and put a
lot of [__] Francis was yanking him
up throwing him around doing whatever he
wanted yeah and shout out to Francis
conditioner like I thought he was winded
earlier and then yo he was still came
back yeah I thought by like the fifth
round I was like okay I think Tyson got
it now he's going to win every round and
then it was like the eighth round where
Francis was like just G I like wow this
I did not expect yeah what about Deontay
wild or Francis I think it'd be an
amazing fight everybody will watch it
Francis injects interest and and
excitement into the heavyweight division
Tyson had dominated so much that people
stopped caring and now every fighter
Anthony Joshua Francis inano would be
huge I would love to see that do you
think that match up would be more equal
in a way like Deontay and Francis just
because of power yeah but here's the
thing if Francis boxes as well here's
the thing if Tyson couldn't hurt Francis
yeah Deontay is gonna test that chin
that's where I I'm if de Wilder's
Knockouts are so Savage I'm like it's
hard to watch and Tyson
landed that's my point like Tyson is a
better boxer but Deontay might be a
harder opponent that's the thing and
you're 100% right there because Tyson
did land Francis could walk through it
and that's a problem I don't think you
can walk through Deontay I don't think
there's a human on this planet that can
walk through Deontay so Tyson might be a
better fight for Francis right Anthony
Joshua has a lot of Pop maybe that's a
tougher fight but this specific one
where it was a guy whose power wasn't so
dominant that he can't walk through it
and his power is really effective it
might have been the perfect one but he's
still in he has one more massive boxing
fight if you want he has two more he has
a rematch with Tyson whenever you want
and we're all buying that in a [__]
heartbeat if I'm him I actually wait for
that I go [__] the I go I tell uh Tyson
to say [__] the the usyk fight hold off
on the usyk fight let's do another fight
for your
belt but yeah yeah that I that's the
fight I want to see that is the fight I
want to see I want to see that rematch
yeah because I that's what want to see I
would love to see him fight Joshua too
Joshua Deontay Wilder I think would be
the biggest money fight because
power it's power and they're going to
land and Deontay is going to throw
godamn and it's going to be Mayhem MH
it's going to be absolute Mayhem yeah
but yeah like heavyweight boxing to be
this EXC those went against each other
who you put in your money on Francis or
Deontay I'd say wild they're yeah just
based off of in terms of winning
probably Deontay really I think yeah I
think after what I saw from Francis I
think I go Fran hard dude it's hard he
was boxing he was
and he was defending and he saw the
things coming also like Tyson is way
more difficult to prepare for than
Deonte Deontay you're watching one hand
the whole fight Tyson you got to watch
everything movement faints the whole
thing so with a guy whose IQ is as
impressive as Francis is maybe he'll
develop a game plan where he can you
know handle that power and also that's
the thing with Francis it's like he's
felt I'm not saying MMA guys MMA
punchers punch as hard as boxers clearly
they don't but he's had
4 o gloves hit him in the face as hard
as possible guys who have like boxing
backgrounds like Stipe I think was a
Golden Gloves like he's boxed and he
walked through it once you walk through
4 ounces you put them pillows on your
hands it's crazy I thought the fight was
going to have 4 oz glove that's what
they initially were saying yeah oh yeah
remember and when that didn't happen I
was like well this isn't even going to
be fun but if it if there's four rounds
gloves Francis wins that fight in the
third round it's over oh God I hit ins
side of the head with 4 o close it's
over yeah Tyson's out most shocking
result any of us ever saw and to be
honest I think he won the fight when
that happened I think we're all like oh
he won whatever happened he doesn't have
to win to win oh yeah and that's the
beauty of I think MMA has injected that
into us where it's just like sometimes
you can win through losing or tying you
know it's France is just an insane human
also what a [__] story I mean
unbelievable it this is kind of a sad
thought but I was like man are there
other Fran that just couldn't make it
here couldn't make it to the thing like
you are the goat there are these and we
like to think most of them make it
through but maybe not D cuz Francis
overcame everything to get here and he
might be the greatest fighter period of
all time maybe bro I don't know fighting
but if you can box like that do UFC like
that like you might be the greatest
fighter ever period yeah so there's
probably other Frances just we never
they're working on a movie right now
they must right I mean [__] a movie I
want a video game bro I want to play his
life on Xbox like you literally start as
a kid [__] do the mining [__] get on
a boat make to America fight a little
bit The Last of Us us as my family he's
last of us but real life I say anything
with Francis as long as it's not a
hypothetical with him [__]
about that's the only thing I don't I
you look at Fran you're like yo you have
to [__] Francis bro I get it I get it
dude I get it that's it all right so
listen uh while we talking about some
sports it's time to get them prize picks
in them Akash locks I actually heard the
Akash locks came through yo I won last
and then this week I did a this is
what's cool about prize picks I did a
six six leg pick yeah during the second
half you can do second half picks so I
did six legs while I was live streaming
the Cowboy game and I only got four of
them still made money priz pick still
paid me even though two missed which no
other nobody else to do that normally
you pick mad [__] you lose and that's it
that's it you're done I'm going hit you
with some NBA picks right now they got
Yousef nurkic mhm he plays for Phoenix s
and a half rebounds I got him doing more
okay I think you get more rebounds than
that
and then Donovan Mitchell five rebounds
against the Knicks because it's the
Knicks I think there's going to be a lot
of Miss shots I'm going to go more there
also so I'm doing more and more on this
one let me know how it works out for you
also use the promo code Schulz you'll
get your initial deposit matched up to
$100 I mean you put in 100 you get a 100
for free so you might as well just do it
respect shout out prize picks man